from risque fashion statements -
adorable power couples
et has an exclusive behind-the-scenes
look inside the Met Gala 2017
after-party kendall Jenner
Bella Hadid and Rihanna were among the
wildest after-party looks at 1oak
nightclub in New York on Monday Bella
with her supermodel pals leaving little
to the imagination in a sheer black
dress
showing her pasties and underwear Haley
Baldwin rocking major cleavage in a
retro mini dress accidentally flashing
her nipple pasties while RiRi narrowly
missed a wardrobe malfunction in an odd
braless ensemble a live couples also
stepped out for fashions biggest night
tom brady escorting his Fairford wife
Gisele inside the bag I have a mic
before after Friday truck so just wait
Kerry Washington hand-in-hand with her
hubby check out Chrissy Teigen and John
Legend mingling with Blake Lively and
Ryan riddles for a kid-free night out
then there's these superstar couples
after making their red carpet debuts
Jennifer Lopez stealing the show with
her dapper boyfriend Alex Rodriguez and
Selena Gomez who can't keep her hands
off her bow the weekend can't keep my
hands to myself
[Music]
no can't keep my